este helicóptero vuelve de la selva
colombiana por un rato lleva días
volando sin parar es parte de la
operación Esperanza que busca rescatar a
cuatro niños perdidos tras un accidente
de avioneta en el que murieron tres
adultos la familia ha pedido que vayan
al lugar líderes espirituales indígenas
y autoridades políticas de distintas
etnias por eso el gobierno también se
pone las botas como Giovanni Yule es el
director de la unidad de restitución de
tierras indígena NASA y organizador de
la minga un espacio para la colaboración
entre distintas comunidades esta minga
que estamos haciendo
es muy infra madre tierra las fuerzas
armadas colaboran para que sean los
conocimientos ancestrales los que guían
la búsqueda un sincretismo desconocido
antes en Colombia en una relación
históricamente basada en la desconfianza
es la misma emoción que despierta el
territorio al que se dirigen una selva
nunca antes explorada por el hombre
repleta de misterios cuando entramos con
la orientación de los y a nuestros
mayores y a nuestros espíritus no nos da
miedo porque ellos nos reciben con
alegría nos reciben bien el helicóptero
vuelve a la selva cargado de expertos
indígenas y de la confianza de las
autoridades en que sean los
conocimientos ancestrales los que tengan
la respuesta a la pregunta de toda
Colombia dónde están